While this entire course will cover many elements of an operating system, it
would be nice to have a simple illustration of what an operating system is like.
So, to give a visual metaphor using our toy theme,
we can say that an operating system is like a toy shop manager.
At a high level, how is a toy shop manager like an operating system?
First, a toy shop manager directs operational resources in the shop.
Second, a toy shop manager enforces working policies.
And finally, a toy shop manager mitigates the difficulty of complex tasks.
For instance, for any toy shop manager, they must be in charge of
their employees and direct their working efforts towards completing the work.
Additionally, a toy shop manager is responsible for scheduling, for allocating,
for distributing the resources in the shop, the parts and the tools, and for
determining which of the employees will work on which orders and
use which tools.
Toy shop managers are also the ones that enforce working policies in
the toy shop.
This can be policies regarding fairness, safety, clean-up.
For instance, how workers working on two different orders have to
share one of the shared resources, shared parts and tools for instance.
Another example is policy regarding how to
clean up after yourselves once a worker is done with processing a toy order.
Finally, a toy shop manager helps mitigate the effects of complex tasks.
It does that by trying to make the overall operation of
the toy shop more optimized and more simple.
Without a manger, for instance, employers may not know how to
establish order among themselves, how to decide, how to handle the workload.
So the toy shop manager has to deal with this situation so
as to avoid dealing with a much more complex task.
So, the question then is,
what parallels are there between a toy shop manager with an operating system?
Operating systems do direct operating resources.
In particular, they control the use of the hardware, CPU,
memory, peripheral devices such as disk, network cards, etc.
And they decide how these resources with be allocated to applications.
Along those lines, operating systems actually enforce some policies.
This can include polices regarding how these resources are used, for
instance, to control fair access to the shared resources.
Or it can be even to impose certain limits to allocate maximum amount of
a certain resource that a particular application or process can use.
Examples of such limits are, for instance,
the number of open files that can be open per process, or some thresholds
that need to be passed in order for some memory management daemons to kick in.
There are numerous other examples of limiting resource usage.
And finally, the operating system helps with the difficulty of complex tasks.
And particularly important is that it simplifies the view of
the underlying hardware that's observed by the applications that
are running on that particular platform.
Instead, applications interact via system calls with the operating system, and
the operating system takes care of managing those difficult tasks for them.